hello China or YouTube is prevalent we
are going to watch today a video
static-x official project regeneration
teaser you see over at our patreon plug
time we do TV show reactions for many of
shows and we also do weekly Q&A s and
also music video coverage primarily from
Humpty Dumpty sat on a wall and today we
have one of our top reward tier quests
and that's whatever video you request we
must definitely do put up on the
youtubes we actually have one that just
came out that's actually not a reaction
so appreciate that this one is a
reaction and I gave this man a proper
shout out a few days ago Tyler Haig stop
waiting on that PS basically for this
video he sent me a message here it says
I know you guys already done a shout out
for me but he didn't do his patron video
request yet he was wondering if we could
spread the word about this and he will
love us even more you better mean that
this was his favorite band and they
broke up and then the lead singer died
and now the original members are doing
this you say it won't put up as fine art
chocolates to the video whatever I said
no John no piece Wayne static I actually
have never heard very little static exes
music but they used to tour with
Powerman 5000 really soft spot in my
heart so I'm curious quite about this I
actually just heard that they were doing
this I have never heard of static X
you're gonna love it Greg I just know
that you of all people this is gonna be
your bag baby oh is it like heavy metal
nah dude it's like singer/songwriter
stuff it's like a little bit of a blues
inflection you know like a nice stompy
beats really introspective lyrics about
perseverance and overcoming pain it's
gonna be great
[Music]
[Music]
well yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Wisconsin huh pilot shop it's like
hometown heroes right now
[Music]
what exactly's de campos ritual basis
and county member with a ban step kicks
butt the 20th anniversary of Wisconsin
Death Trip coming right around the
corner it feels like the right time to
pay our respects to the band to Wayne
and to all the fans that supported us
right from the start
long time sir wild original band lineup
myself 20 Campos guitars screeching CUDA
and coverage in June we're in the
process of completing the brand new
stack ex-army Rock generation and will
feature the final vocal performances in
musical compositions for Wednesday Wow
[Music]
finish tracks we're inviting our friends
to lend us their vocal talents to help
us complete this very personal project
Oh sentence both a making we are in the
process of reaching out to Raymon
from the stern movie punch ministry
spider sorry no spider and these in a
handful
[Music]
if somebody makes with this album to be
between 12 and 15 brand new static
stress
[Music]
at the street
[Music]
original lineup back together with all
the right reasons the stock seat s trip
was our biggest record you know except
the tone for everything we did from
there on out we're gonna celebrate the
warmest of responses that trip with you
while we properly pay our respects to
our brother Dwayne each and every night
as part of the 20th anniversary
Wisconsin Death Trip reunion through
wait now fans everywhere you know so why
not do a memorial show for him
everywhere I'm a killer
Elite School said that features the
majority of desperate
[Music]
Yolo
[Music]
it's gonna generate and the board will
be able to do we go
I want to thank you so much that gets to
the scampi will get their names in the
liner notes we out we put off some
reliable bags history along with brand
new static instructor Judy
in bundles deposit regeneration along
with a bunch of wolves playing static-x
items to celebrate the 20th anniversary
Wisconsin country you know we feel
really grateful that we have such a
loyal fan base that misses the band then
this is Wayne and I know we appreciate
all the hard effort that we're putting
into this www static-x org born in foe
thank you guys so much
bollocks for throughout all the years
[ __ ] love you guys I'll see you guys
soon out on the road
I've seen these guys before yeah
definitely seen them before Wayne static
that giant hmm cuz I've always been
staking him for Dane Cook ha ha ha hey I
could see what like early days to Hank
yeah I have seen this guy before you
actually like how they handle that video
because you know when you hear that a
lead singer died I'm gonna put together
something I especially a lot more you
know yeah yeah and this one was just
about keeping to what their music is
yeah I don't really listen to industrial
metal what do you mean serious it's
usually what I'm blasting I know yeah
you know especially when you're like
writing and stuff yeah focus in your
life we're gonna get them a heavy metal
go and helps me a constant sureiy to
meditate yeah there was something about
this where I thought it was rather
charming in the way they handled it what
they didn't seem like they were being
pretentious at all they were just doing
it to honor their music here in the
Wisconsin Death Trip I mean Tyler
Hague's from Wisconsin makes sense why
he loves these guys so much there's
actually a band from California though
cuz for a second doing the videos like
these like hometown heroes are so yeah
yeah they just name-check the stakes
maybe one of them's from Wisconsin
originally or something yeah I find the
industrial metal like any part of the
metal crowd very interesting because of
the kind of music you hear and you see
the music videos and stuff you tend to
imagine that these guys would be
something were they're very angsty it
angry and they're violent yeah you don't
expect it to be as warm on the edges
yeah but then when you ever you meet
someone in the bands or you meet people
who wasn't like other eggs a perfect
example of that same thing with the
horror community there's like the nicest
people in the world you always expect
some like dark
they never are that I guess it's that
recreational catharsis when just the
thing
you enjoy the so aggressive it's
probably easier just to let the let out
and and I do I appreciate that too about
this video overall metal industrial just
that community in general can be very
tight woven especially over bands that
people love and yeah like that so I can
imagine there probably is a very
ingrained static-x community and to have
this be something that does feel very
personal and very loving and very much
in memoriam of Wayne I like the idea too
that they're gonna have a bunch of their
friends come in and complete this record
with them because that can be kind of
ghoulish to do posthumous stuff like
there's always a debate over it as to
whether it's just making money off the
name and the circumstances or if it
really is heartfelt and this felt
heartfelt this feel heartfelt and the
way they handle the video felt authentic
in tune with how their fan base is and
who their family says they don't strike
me as a huge fan you know they strike me
as a as a band that has loyal follower
yeah who could still you know pack a
club show touring around the country
yeah exactly and this the Wayne guy died
at 48 years old and that's an early ass
time times it's a few years ago when it
happened huh yeah oh wow
first hearing about this yeah it's been
a minute open damn they've had songs
appearing some [ __ ] I've seen Marvel's
Punisher Wars I saw three yeah dude no
that was in the actual movie yeah hell
yeah awesome
I'm sure yeah they seem like them
empower man or a bunch of those bands
that came up around that time you've
probably heard them in a fair few I said
yeah well it's been four years since
Wayne died but it's interesting to see
them come back before this and I get the
original guys back together too because
I know that's always a big deal for
everybody especially if that first album
was there you know pinnacle they're
they're huge kick-off album you know to
have those guys all back together has to
be pretty special yeah Wayne will be
there yeah he's gonna have a Wayne
hologram and I don't want to field not
conflate this video didn't do something
for me where I'm like I'm gonna listen
to so much static accident what however
it did like give me this respect and I'm
hoping that whatever they're setting out
on all these things are talking about
that it is a major success like I really
want it to be for them when I hope that
gets a tour like Europe and Canada
stuff too with this like it seems like
to do a memoriam each night would be
pretty special they should skip their
hometown Los Angeles yeah don't play
here you guys play all the shows rocks
bad enough as donut can make it work
skip the whiskey but if they did play
here John and I would go just a video it
so I could show Tyler Hague that we were
here just for him yeah we'll get you
some merchants and mail it to you but
we'll sign it
this is what I imagine the guys would
have written on your shirt much love
Greg shot this I mean for the static-x
fans I'm really happy for them cuz it's
been almost four years or something like
that around that time frame since as
bands come back together so this must be
a very exciting time for all those
people and I hope this is a success and
if you are a setting expand you didn't
know about this hopefully this video
introduced you in some capacity yo get
out there and let the let out get heavy
man alright guys well thanks for tuning
and you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell
check us out patreon we all that [ __ ] we
talked about earlier